my journey away from
violent extremism began 22 years ago
when i denounced racism and left the
american white supremacist skinhead
movement that i'd helped build
i was just 22 years old at the time but
i had already spent eight years
from the time i was 14 years old as one
of the earliest and youngest members
and an eventual leader within america's
most violent
hate movement but i wasn't born into
hate
in fact it was quite the opposite
i had a relatively normal childhood
my parents are italian immigrants who
came to the united states in the
mid-1960s
and settled on the south side of chicago
where they eventually met
and opened a small beauty shop
right after i was born things got a
little bit more difficult they struggle
to survive
with raising a young family and a new
business
often working seven days a week 14 hours
a day
taking on second and third jobs just to
earn a meager living
and quality time with my parents was
pretty non-existent
even though i knew they loved me very
much
growing up i felt abandoned
i was lonely and i started to withdraw
and then i started to resent my parents
and become very angry
and as i was growing up through my
teenage years i started to act out
to try and get attention from my parents
and one day when i was 14 i was standing
in an alley
and i was smoking a joint and a man who
was twice my age
with a shaved head and tall black boots
came up to me and he snatched the joint
from my lips
then he put his hand on my shoulder and
he looked me in the eyes
and he said that's what the communists
and the jews
want you to do to keep you docile
i was 14 years old i'd been trading
baseball cards and watching happy days i
didn't really know what a jew was
it's true and the only communist that i
knew was the
you know bad russian guy in my favorite
rocky movie
and since i'm here bearing my soul with
you i can reveal that i did not even
know what the word docile meant
dead serious but it was as if this man
in this alley
had offered me a lifeline for 14 years
i'd felt marginalized and bullied
i had low self-esteem and frankly i
didn't know who i
was where i belonged or what my purpose
was
i was lost and overnight
because this man had pulled me in and i
had grabbed on
to that lifeline with every fiber of my
being
i'd gone from joni loves chachi
to full-blown nazi overnight
i started to listen to the rhetoric
and believe it i started to watch very
closely as the leaders of this
organization
would target vulnerable young people
who felt marginalized and then draw them
in
with promises of paradise that were
broken
and then i started to recruit myself
i started to do that by making white
power music
and soon i became the leader of that
infamous
organization that was led by that man in
that alley
who recruited me that day who was
america's first
neo-nazi skinhead and who had
radicalized me
for the next eight years i believed
the lies that i had been fed and though
i saw no evidence of it whatsoever
i didn't hesitate to blame every jewish
person in the world
for what i thought was a white european
genocide
being promoted by them through a
multiculturalist
agenda i blamed people of color
for the crime the violence and the drugs
in the city completely neglecting the
fact that i was committing acts of
violence
on a daily basis and that in many cases
it was white supremacists who were
funneling drugs
into the inner cities and i blamed
immigrants for taking jobs
from white americans completely
neglecting the fact
that my parents were hard-working
immigrants
who struggled to survive
despite not getting help from anybody
else
for the next eight years i saw
friends die i saw others go to prison
and inflict untold pain on countless
victims
and her family's lives i heard horrific
stories from young women in the movement
who'd been brutally raped by the very
men that they were conditioned to trust
and i myself committed acts of violence
against people solely for the color of
their skin
who they loved or the god that they
prayed to
i stockpiled weapons for what i thought
was an upcoming race war
i went to six high schools i was kicked
out of four of them
one of them twice and 25 years ago
i wrote and performed racist music
that found its way to the internet
decades later and partially inspired
a young white nationalist to walk into a
sacred
charleston south carolina church and
senselessly massacre
nine innocent people
but then my life changed
at 19 years old i met a girl who was not
in the movement who didn't have a racist
bone in her body
and i fell in love with her and at 19 we
got married
and we had our first son
and when i held my son in my arms in the
delivery room that day
not only did i reconnect with some of
the innocents that i had lost
at 14 years old but it also began to
challenge the very
important things that drew me to the
movement to begin with
identity community and purpose things
that i had been struggling with
as a young boy and now
i struggled with the concept of who i
was again
was i this neo-nazi
hate monger or was i a caring father
and husband was my community the one
that i had manufactured around me to
boost my own ego
because i felt self-hatred for myself
and i wanted to project it onto others
or was it the one that i had physically
given life to
my purpose to scorch the earth
or was it to make it a better place for
my family
and suddenly like a ton of bricks hit me
i became very confused with who i'd been
for the last eight years
and if only i'd been brave enough to
walk away at that moment
to understand what the struggle was that
was happening inside
of me then maybe tragedy could have been
averted
instead i did compromise i took myself
off the streets for the benefit of my
family
because i was nervous that maybe i could
go to jail or end up dead and they would
have to fend for themselves
so i stepped back as a leader and
instead i opened
a record store that
i was going to sell white power music in
of course because i was importing it in
from europe
but i knew that if i was just a racist
store selling
racist music that the community would
not allow me to be there
so i decided i was gonna also stock the
shelves with other music
like punk rock and heavy metal and hip
hop
and while the white power music that i
was selling was 75 percent of my gross
revenue because people were driving in
from all over the country to buy it
from the only store that was selling it
i also had customers come in to buy the
other music
and eventually they started to talk to
me
and one day young black
teen came in and he was visibly upset
and i decided to ask him what was wrong
and he told me that his mother had been
diagnosed with breast cancer
and suddenly this young black teenager
who i'd never had a meaningful
conversation or interaction with
i was able to connect with because my
own mother
had been diagnosed with breast cancer
and i could feel
his pain on another occasion a gay
couple came in with their son
and it was undeniable to me that they
loved their son
in the same profound ways that i loved
mine
and suddenly i couldn't rationalize or
justify the prejudice
that i had in my head i decided to pull
the white power music from the inventory
when i became too embarrassed to sell it
in front of my new friends
and of course the store couldn't sustain
itself so i had to close it
at that same time i lost nearly
everything
in my life i used it as an opportunity
to
walk away from the movement that i'd
been a part of for eight years
the only identity community and purpose
that i'd really known for most of my
life
so i had nobody i
lost my livelihood because i closed the
store i didn't have a great relationship
with my parents
even though they tried and my wife and
children left me because i hadn't left
the movement
and disengaged quickly enough
and suddenly
i didn't know who i was again or where i
fit in
or what my purpose was supposed to be
i was miserable inside and i often woke
up
in the morning wishing that i hadn't
about five years in one of the few
friends that i had
was concerned about my well-being and
she came to me and she said you need to
do something because i don't want to see
you die
and she suggested that i go apply for a
job where she worked
at a company called ibm
yeah i thought she was crazy too
here i was a closeted ex-nazi covered in
hate tattoos
i didn't go to college i'd been kicked
out of multiple high schools
multiple times i didn't even own a
computer
but i went in and somehow miraculously
i got the job i was
thrilled and then i became terrified to
learn
that they'd actually be putting me back
at my old high school
the same one i got kicked out of twice
to install their computers this was a
high school
where i had committed acts of violence
against students against faculty
where i'd protested out in front of the
school for equal rights for whites
and even had a sit-in in the cafeteria
to try and demand a white student union
and of course as karma would have it
within the first couple of hours who
walks right by me
but mr johnny holmes the tough black
security guard i'd gotten in a fist
fight with
that got me kicked out the second time
and let out in handcuffs from the school
he didn't recognize me but i saw him
and i didn't know what to do i was
frozen i was this grown man now
years out of the movement and i was
sweating and i was trembling
but i decided i had to do something
and i decided i needed to suffer under
the weight of my past
because for five years i had tried to
outrun it
i tried to make new friends and cover my
tattoos with long sleeves and i wouldn't
admit it because
i was afraid of being judged the same
way that i had judged other people
well i decided i was going to chase mr
holmes out to the parking lot
probably not the smartest decision that
i made
but when i found him he was getting into
his car and i tapped him on the shoulder
and when he turned around and he
recognized me
he took a step back because he was
afraid
and i didn't know what to say
finally the words came out of my mouth
and all i could think to say was
i'm sorry and he embraced me
and he forgave me
and he encouraged me to forgive myself
he recognized that it wasn't the story
of some
broken go nowhere kid who was going to
just join a gang and go to prison
he knew that this was the story of every
young
person who was vulnerable who was
searching for identity
community and purpose and then hit a
wall and was unable to find it
and went down a dark path
and he made me promise one thing that i
would tell my story to whoever
would listen that was 18 years ago and
i've been doing it ever since
you might be asking yourself right now
how does a good kid from a you know
hard-working immigrant family end up
going down such a
dark path one word potholes
that's right potholes i had a lot of
potholes when i was a kid
we all have them you know the things in
life that
we hit that invariably just kind of
nudge us off our path and if they remain
unresolved or untreated
or not dealt with sometimes we can get
dangerously lost down pretty dark
corridors
potholes can be things like trauma abuse
unemployment neglect
untreated mental health conditions even
privilege
and if we hit enough potholes on our
journey in life
and we don't have the resources or the
help to navigate around them or to pull
us out
well sometimes good people end up doing
bad things
one such person who had potholes is
daryl
daryl is from upstate new york and he
had read my memoir
and he was really upset about the ending
you see i had gotten out of the movement
and he was still in
and uh you know he emailed me and he
said you know
i i didn't really like the way that
turned out and i said well you know i'm
sorry
but if you want to talk about it we
could certainly do that
and after a couple of weeks of going
back and forth with daryl i learned he
was a 31 year old
military veteran who had been injured
and
was really angry about not being able to
go to afghanistan to kill muslims
and one day on the phone he told me that
he had seen a muslim man in the park
praying and that all he wanted to do
was kick him in the face i flew to
buffalo the next day
and i sat down with daryl and i asked
him
have you ever met a muslim person before
and he said no why the hell would i want
to do that they're evil i don't want
anything to do with them i said okay
so i excused myself and i went into the
bathroom and i took my phone out in the
bathroom
and i googled the local mosque and i
called them very quietly from the
bathroom and i said uh
excuse me imam um i need a favor i have
a christian man who would really love to
learn more about your religion
do you mind if we stop by
well it took some convincing for daryl
to go but finally we got there
and when i knocked on the door the imam
said he only had 15 minutes left for us
because he was preparing for a prayer
service
i said we'll take it we went in
and two and a half hours later we came
out
after hugging and crying and very
strangely bonding over
chuck norris for some reason i don't
know what
what it was about that but that's what
happened
and i'm happy to say now that daryl and
the imam
you can often find them at the local
falafel stand having
lunch together
you see it's our disconnection from each
other hatred is born of ignorance
fear is its father in isolation
is its mother when we don't understand
something we tend to be afraid of it and
if we keep ourselves from it
that fear grows and sometimes it turns
into hatred
since i've left the movement i've helped
over a hundred people disengage from
extremist movements from white
supremacist groups
to even jihadist groups and the way i do
that
is not by arguing with them not by
debating them
not by even telling them they're wrong
even though boy i want to sometimes
i don't do that instead
i don't push them away i draw them in
closer
and i listen very closely for their
potholes
and then i begin to fill them in i try
to make people more resilient
more self-confident more able
to have skills to compete in the
marketplace so that they don't have to
blame
the other the other that they've never
met
i'd like to just leave you with one last
thing before i go
of all the people i've worked with they
will all tell you the same thing
one they became extremists
because they wanted to belong not
because of ideology or dogma
and second what brought them out
was receiving compassion from the people
they least deserved it from
when they least deserved it
so i would like to leave you with a
challenge go out there today
tomorrow hopefully every day find
somebody that you think is undeserving
of your compassion
and give it to them because i guarantee
you
they're the ones who need it the most
thank you very much